in May of 2015 it was the witcher this
Emma which are that all which are all
the time but for good reason the witcher
3 wild hunt is a phenomenal role-playing
game and a worthy recipient of the
public's attention take a step back
however and the juggernaut that is the
witcher 3 becomes part of a larger
tapestry into which other excellent and
influential games were woven garel casts
a large shadow of course but his shadow
doesn't spill into outer space where
kerbal space program reveals its
well-earned prestige kerbal gained a
huge following during its years of early
access availability so it's official
release seemed almost like an
afterthought the game coming as it did
with a dedicated fan base and years of
updates to power its popularity it's a
game that defies categorization a space
travel simulation that lets you play the
role of engineer commander pilot and
space Walker it's a niche game a
difficult game and a must play game
unique and strange and wonderful where
kerbal space program can finds you to a
single solar system Galactic
Civilizations 3 delivers a galaxy to
your doorstep inviting you to crisscross
the harsh vacuum of space one turn at a
time like so many games of its ilk gal
sib 3 is about exploration exploitation
expansion and extermination what makes
it special is that it does all of that
for xing remarkably well and with lots
of customization and a heavy dose of dry
humor it might be a highly technical
game but it's not lacking personality
and alien flavor meanwhile back on terra
firma project cars is all but
overwhelmed by its devotion to the
technical elements of driving fast cars
in beautiful places by dumping the
progression systems that bogged down
other simulations it allows you to own
the road and the supercar of your
choosing from the moment you boot it up
just don't expect to be an immediate
master of the open road alas and the
lack for those games anyway Gerald
silver sword has vanquished these
monsters in the race for game of the
month of May 2015 you can nitpick the
specifics but it's hard to deny that the
witcher 3 wild hunt is a
great accomplishment garol The Witcher
of the game's title is a stoic presence
in an unwelcome world as he navigates
one of gaming's most exquisitely crafted
lands he witnesses couples finding love
amid horror and politicians enduring the
turbulence of unhappy citizens choice
and consequence come to have great
meaning as you alter the course of
people's lives all while galloping
across mysterious bogs and battling
ferocious inspiring monsters no game has
it all but the witcher 3 wild hunt has
an air of totality giving you everything
you might want in an open-air RPG
feeling simultaneously enormous and
intimate creating personal connections
and kingdoms that stretch on for many
miles congratulations The Witcher 3 for
inspiring in us a great urge to explore
and for earning gamespot's award for
game of the month of May 2015